high value woman to me or to you
um I thought you woman is someone who
first of all has a lot of respect for
herself you know
um has a lot of like Pride you know
works hard men want prideful hard
workers
[Music]
well I I feel like no because men
obviously just want someone who's
beautiful and is just gonna be
submissive and say yes and well that's
at least what we're being told but I
feel like I think that's not true
no men don't like submissive women no I
don't think so no because I feel like
it's not about being submissive you just
have to be kind and you have to be
loving and you have to respect your man
a lot of women don't actually respect
their men yes they like them they're
attracted to them they love them but
they don't actually respect them and I
feel like men want respect from women
and they don't get that enough well I
agree with you but why is that not
submission isn't that part of submission
no because I still have a voice you
don't think submissive women have voices
I don't know I feel like if I'm just
going to be saying yes to everything and
doing everything that my man wants then
I've kind of lost sense of who I am like
I want to have a voice in this
partnership I want to have a voice in
this marriage and I want to be heard and
I want to be seen submission is like
he's your boss so your boss can take
your opinion into account but at the end
of the day Here's the final say and men
don't they don't feel like they're
respected if you don't give them the
final say like they don't want a woman
that they have to argue with all the
time yeah but you don't have to argue
with a man to get your point across if
you're with a loving respectful man who
hears you and values you he's always
going to listen to you he can he can
hear you and listen to you and still
tell you no
if he tells me no
it it depends like there's there's
certain things that yeah I might be like
okay cool I'll submit to you because I
would say I'm definitely a traditional
woman and there are you a virgin
I'm sorry I'm saying how are you
tradition a traditional woman is a 22
year old virgin no as in I have like
Traditional Values the way that I was
brought I'm Arab I'm Moroccan we are
brought up in a certain way
um and the men that I see in my culture
are very traditional they're providers
you know they go out they make money and
a lot of women in my culture they don't
work they just sort of stay at home and
the man goes out and gets the money and
they just raise the kids obviously we've
moved on from that but I still hold
those values in the sense that I'm okay
to submit to my man when the time is
right or when I feel the time is right
but the whole point is that's that's not
submission is when you feel I mean we're
women we change our opinions every
goddamn day we don't
half the time so it's like if you if if
I if I employ blessing and I say
blessing turn this camera angle on or I
do do this do this and at the end of the
day I have the final say and and that's
kind of how it is should be anyways when
you're submitting to a guy
so so you're saying that's what men want
they just want someone to go yes I'll do
exactly what you tell me to do no they
just want to argue all the time with
every decision
I'm kidding
I know they just want to fight every day
I personally think they're gonna have
long conversations about every decisions
and just really make you feel heard
wow I feel like yeah I don't know I I
will submit to the right man um and if I
feel comfortable but I will always have
my boundaries but set in place sometimes
you're not going to feel comfortable I
mean in a 30 40 50 year marriage you
think you're not going to feel
comfortable
and sometimes you're gonna feel like
he's not the right man I mean every day
yeah 100 so tell me more about the high
value woman what else
I mean the high value woman is like
someone who like is kind who's nurturing
you know
um who's gonna support her man lift him
up motivate him Inspire him
um you know is is fun she has that
feminine energy that men crave
um you know the list goes on and I know
that men are not stupid they know when
they come across a high value woman they
know
um so yeah do you want to know what I
hear when I hear high value woman oh God
designer
she won all that Instagram like
highlighted Factor like Valentine's Day
you better make sure that like you've
got a hotel with the little petals and
the balloons like holidays it's like
it's like give me everything
I mean you know what I mean
to me what I'm hearing when I'm here
they read why a maintenance woman is
it's money in it you need money for that
it's like it's like whenever I hear that
I think of the book why men love
it's like they read that book and then
it's like that's the whole I'm not
saying you personally it's just that's
always what I hear
um okay so what percent of the financial
family load do you guys expect to pay to
carry for a lifetime
ten percent
ten percent ten percent okay
um yeah I would say ten percent
10 percent
I think it changes I think it's like
situational I mean
ideally like
maybe 40
um but I think it changes like you never
know what's gonna happen the man might
suddenly go unemployed so you know I'm
gonna have to pick up extra shifts here
and there and then I might go unemployed
or go on maternity leave and the man's
gonna take over I think it fluctuates
depending on the the situation
come on
um yeah I'm kind of the same there as
well
um I also like as you said like
maternity leave or if I if the man said
that he wanted me to be a housewife
which I don't think I would ever like
take up to do but if he did then I'd
expect him to do 100 then I'll be doing
the cookie and I'll be doing the
cleaning but if like I'm working he's
working like I don't expect him to say
that I'm gonna be a complete housewife
because there's some men that like
percent
I don't know zero percent depending okay
so you think you should carry a hundred
percent of the bills
no that's not true I don't think so I
think I'm just using it okay if I'm
cooking and clean it 50 50 50. okay you
okay so we went from 100 to 50 50. no
depending okay what does it depend on if
I'm working or if I'm not okay do you
want to work or do you not I do
um okay so I would say 50 50. yeah
yeah I don't I can't think of a percent
I actually can't been um
yeah I don't know
are we considering that there's kids
involved here yeah yeah are you sure I
mean unless unless you don't I feel like
I want to change my answer now
all right I'm just gonna say numbers
raise your hand is there a wide camera
do we have one though
that was four I think it's Dependable on
the circumstances though because like if
if you're green that you stay at home
like if I'm staying at home then well
I'm asking if you zero percent if I'm at
home
um
I've had been with my partner and I've
been at home like he wants me at home so
I can't go to work so as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible